with almost 500 sessions at next 2019
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see
migrating from a monolith to
micro-services then stay tuned because
here's the rewind what we've got here is
an overview of what you could expect
from your own migration brought to you
by two of Dells finest Adam ross and
martin omander walk through the
advantages and some common hiccups of
refactoring a company's monolithic
infrastructure into something that's
lighter more agile and maintainable
thanks to micro services let's pause
what are micro services anyway and does
your system qualify as a monolith is
that bad well I don't actually know
about your system but a monolith system
is fully interconnected meaning every
piece is part of a single whole we're
updating one feature means rebuilding
and redeploying the entire system as a
contrast microservices are independently
built deployed operated and scaled they
connect to other services by calling
each other but they are not constructed
or hosted established whatever you want
to call it together in the talk myron
explains that a micro service has for
defining characteristics an api which is
the only way to communicate with the
service compare resources to you know
run business logic some sort of state
could be database storage a file system
in memory cache whatever it needs and
most importantly according to Martin a
team that is associated with it someone
inside the company to turn to if
something goes monkey this leads to the
core trade-off that adam and martin
discuss development versus operations
reducing technical complexity makes it
easier to update and fix your code but
requires more operational effort more
deployments harder troubleshooting etc
so the secret sauce for these two
serverless a serverless approach handles
most of your operational complexity
making this trade-off irrelevant and
with micro-services cutting down on
technical complexity your company can
move to an agile adaptable place to
prove that adam and martin had a
complete micro service introduced within
46 seconds of their talk beginning
sure technically it was a super simple
cloud function but that is still a
complete micro service deployed with a
one-liner that is the agility they are
here to show off so if I've caught your
interest you're going to want to see the
talk because they managed to use a
fictional company's journey as an
iterative demo that creates a relatable
migration story for anyone who thinks
micro services are their future but may
have some concerns about getting started
because while these two are showing off
the power of cloud functions cloud run
cloud fire store cloud tasks and Google
sheets they are also calling out
pitfalls like data fragmentation or
component change scaling at different
rates
all around advice from two people who
have your back if you'd like to see the
full talk check out the link in the
description below and don't forget to
subscribe to the cloud youtube channel
for more great next to rewind content
thanks for watching
[Music]